There's no way
that he can win.
No, mm-mm, no.
So, anyway, what did you think
of the season finale
of Game of Thrones?
- [gasps]
- Right?
- That was--
- No, no, no.
I'm reading
the books.
Oh, sorry, sorry,
sorry, sorry.
And he reads slow.
[laughter]
We can never
talk about it.
We're never
gonna talk about it.
Okay.
- Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
- Uh-huh.
Hey, has anybody seen
that new Russell Crowe thriller?
'Cause let me tell--
Ah, ah, ah!
Ah.
Sorry, it's just
we're going tomorrow,
and I don't want to know
a thing about it.
Doesn't want
to know a thing.
- Got you. Okay, all right.
- Sure, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
That is--
How--who won the game?
- I think--
- N-n-n-n-n-n-n.
That--I'm--
I'm gonna watch it later.
- Oh, you're--
- Oh, you have a DVR.
- I got it--
- Sorry, okay.
Mum's the word.
- Yeah.
- So...
What's the weather
gonna be like this--
[squawking]
[dog barking in the distance]
Sorry.
It's, uh...
[sighs]
We're having
a barbecue this weekend,
and I don't want to stress
about the weather.
- No, of course you don't.
- We just--Yeah.
Yeah.
You know, yeah.
[clears throat]
This three-bean
casserole is--
[scatting]
I'm so sorry, babe.
I just--
- I hadn't tasted them yet.
- I'm sorry.
- Really looking forward to it.
You know?
Don't talk about
the ingredients, I know.
It's a surprise
for your mouth.
- Yeah.
- Really.
Oh, uh...
[laughs]
You know that
commercial with--
Okay, never--
Oh.
[laughs]
[laughing]
Okay.
(woman)
Never mind.
That's probably best.
- Yeah.
- [clears throat]
Oh.
No, it's fine.
- Cheesecake.
- [gasps]
- What?
- Huh?
We got cheesecake.
- I mean...
- Oh, yeah.
No, I'd love
some cheesecake.
- Yeah.
- Let's do that.
All right,
what the hell?
- Okay, cheesecake.
- Cheesecake.
I mean, I've been watching
my cholesterol intake,
but what the hell, right?
We're all gonna die
someday anyway.
- What?
- Honey.
- Wow.
- Come on.
Are you
kidding me?
You just ruin it
every time!
I'll see you
at home.
- But wait a second.
- So rude!
Now, how would you not know
that that was taking place?